c'est comme un autre et ce n'est pas le
soir de continuer l'école à dans mon
fils est privé de ma liberté je veux
montrer
ses crocs
la bête
reconstruire et braver les foules tu
fais des labels chantant boum boum boum
rencontre des braves
oh
hahaha
qu'attend on
en
ah
ah ah ah
et plus
non
tél
une heure
et pour le combat et qui fait pour
avancer sans
regarder en face avec vous
le maire ferait au pouvoir non ce qui me
semble
beauchamp qui se défoulent fou
vous verrez la baisse en travaux
pour construire et brave et les photos
libérez la bête en temps mon bon
contre les bases ennemies
oh
parmi nous
mondialement
des plus suspens
je sois
ma
encore
non non non
d
m
enfin le prix
et
encore
ah